[Music]
during these times there was a
pestilence by which the whole human race
came near to being annihilated now in
the case of all other scourge is sent
from heaven some explanation of a cause
might be given by daring men such as the
many theories propounded by those who
are clever in these matters but for this
calamity it is quite impossible either
to express in words or to conceive in
thought any explanation except indeed to
refer it to God for it did not come in a
part of the world nor upon certain men
nor did it confine itself to any season
of the year so that from such
circumstances it might be possible to
find subtle explanations of a cause but
it embraced the entire world and
blighted the lives of all men though
differing from one another in the most
mark to degree respecting neither sex
nor age for much as men differ with
regard to places in which they live or
in the law of their daily life or in
natural bent or in active pursuits or in
whatever else man it differs from man in
the case of this disease alone the
difference availed nought and it
attacked some in the summer season
others in the winter and still others at
the other times of the year now let each
one express his own judgment concerning
the matter both sophist and astrologer
but as for me I shall proceed to tell
where this disease originated and the
manner in which it destroyed men
it started from the Egyptians who dwell
in Pelusium
then it divided and moved in one
direction towards Alexandria and the
rest of Egypt and in the other direction
it came to Palestine on the borders of
Egypt and from there it spread over the
whole world always moving forward and
traveling at times favourable to it for
it seemed to move by fixed arrangement
and to tarry for a specified time in
each country casting its light
slightingly upon none but spreading in
either direction right out to the ends
of the world as if fearing lest some
corner of the earth might escape it for
it left neither island nor cave no
mountain ridge which had human
inhabitants and if it passed by any land
either not affecting the men there or
touching them in in different fashion
still at a later time it came back then
those who dwelt round about this land
who formerly it had affected most sorely
it did not touch at all but it did not
remove from the place in question until
it had given up its just and proper tale
of dead so as to correspond exactly to
the number destroyed at the earlier time
among those who dwelt round about and
this disease always took its start from
the coast and from there went up to the
interior and in the second year it
reached Byzantium in the middle of
spring where it happened that I was
staying at the time and it came as
follows apparitions of supernatural
beings in human guise of every
description was seen by many persons and
those who encountered them thought that
they were struck by the man they had met
in this or that part of the body as it
haven't--
and immediately upon seeing this
apparition they were seized also by the
disease
now at first those who saw the creatures
tried to turn them aside by uttering the
holiest of names and exercising them in
other ways as well as each one could but
they accomplished absolutely nothing for
even in the sanctuaries where the most
of them fled for refuge they were dying
constantly but later on they were
unwilling even to give heed to their
friends when they called to them and
they shut themselves up in their rooms
and pretended that they did not hear
although their doors were being beaten
down fearing obviously that he who was
calling was one of those demons but in
the case of some of the pestilence did
not come on in this way but they saw a
vision in a dream and seemed to suffer
the very same thing at the hands of the
creature who stood over them or else to
hear a voice for telling to them that
they were written down in the number of
those who would die but with the
majority it came about that they were
seized by the disease without becoming
aware of what was coming either through
a waking vision or a dream and they were
taken in the following manner
they had a sudden fever some when just
roused from sleep others while walking
about and others while otherwise engaged
without any regard to what they were
doing and the body showed no change from
its previous color nor was it hot as
might be expected when attacked by a
fever nor indeed did any inflammation
set in but the fever was of such a
language sword from its commencement and
up till evening that neither to the sick
themselves nor to a physician who
touched them would it afford any
suspicion of danger it was natural
therefore that not one of those who had
contracted the disease expected to die
from it but on the same day in some
cases in others on the following day and
in the rest not so many days later a
bubonic swelling developed
and this took place not only in the
particular part of the body which is
called boo bong that is below the
abdomen but also inside the armpit and
in some cases also beside the ears and
at different points on the thighs up to
this point then everything went in about
the same way with all who had taken the
disease but from then on very marked
differences developed and I am unable to
say whether the cause of this diversity
of symptoms was to be found in the
differences in bodies or in the fact
that it followed the wish of him who
brought the disease into the world so
there ensued with some a deep coma with
others a violent delirium in either case
they suffered the characteristic
symptoms of the disease for those who
were under the spell of the coma forgot
all those who are familiar to them and
seemed to lie sleeping constantly and if
anyone cared for them they would eat
without waking but some also were
neglected and these would die directly
through lack of sustenance but those who
were seized with delirium suffered from
insomnia and were victims of a distorted
imagination for they suspected that men
were coming upon them to destroy them
and they would become excited and rush
off in a flight crying out at the top of
their voices and when water chance to be
near they wished to fall into it not so
much because of a desire for drink for
the most of them rushed into the sea but
the cause was to be found chiefly in the
diseased state of their minds and in
those cases where neither coma nor
delirium came on the bubonic swelling
became mortified and the sufferer no
longer able to endure the pain died
and one would suppose that in all cases
the same thing would have been true but
since they were not at all in their
senses some were quite unable to feel
the pain throwing to the trouble
condition of their minds they lost all
sense of feeling now the disease in
Byzantium ran a course of four months
and its greatest virulence lasted about
three and at first the deaths were a
little more than the normal then the
mortality Rose still higher and
afterwards the tale of dead reached
5,000 each day and again it came to ten
thousand and still more than that now in
the beginning each man attended to the
burial of the dead of his own house and
these they threw even into the tombs of
others either escaping detection or
using violence but afterwards confusion
and disorder everywhere became complete
for slaves remained destitute of masters
and men who in former times were very
prosperous were deprived of the service
of their domestics who were either sick
or dead and many houses became
completely destitute of human
inhabitants for this reason and came
about that some of the notable men of
the city because of the universal
destitution remained unburied for many
days and it fell to the lot of the
Emperor as was natural to make provision
for the trouble he therefore detailed
soldiers from the palace and distributed
money commanding Theodorus to take
charge of this work this man held the
position of announcer of Imperial
messages always announcing to the
Emperor the petitions of his clients and
declaring to them in turn whatever his
wish was in the Latin tongue the Romans
designate this office by the term refer
and arias so those would not as yet
fallen into complete destitution in
their domestic affairs attended
individually to the burial of those
connected with them but the odorous by
giving out the Emperor's money am I
making further expenditures from his own
purse kept burying the bodies
which were
cared-for and when it came out that all
the tombs which had existed previously
were filled with the dead then they dug
up all the places about the city one
after the other laid the dead there each
one as he could and departed but later
on those who are making the trenches no
longer able to keep up with a number of
the dying mounted the towers of the
fortifications in psychie and tearing
off the roofs through the bodies they're
in complete disorder and they piled them
up just as each one happened to fall and
filled practically all the towers with
corpses and then covered them up again
with their roofs as a result of this an
evil stench pervaded the city and
distressed the inhabitants still more
and especially whenever the wind blew
fresh from that quarter